all right so we are officially in
October and nostalgia weena started I'm
not gonna live one to talk about this
one for a while now you guys before we
get to that oh oh I just want to say one
thing quickly
yes Lawrence Kasdan has directed so
decent films um it's probably gonna be a
couple weeks before my brains back into
gear so just giving you the heads up now
I was gonna say what was there from the
left I am fat I apparently had said that
he had like writers don't always make
good directors and uh I think in the
case of dreamcatcher that still holds up
it was a very talky movie well because I
got way too much evidence on the
dialogue but you know he's done some
other things I don't remember I said but
we're also talking about Yan de Bont and
my brain was still getting confused and
well but I think was with recent events
I'm just a little yeah so yeah but I
know I think like he's he's directed
both he's trying some good films on some
bad yeah so I just want that out there
cuz like people were just like coming to
my face with me like but how could you
say that Woody's I'm just like oh shit
did I say that a sucessful
like wait we have nothing against the
dude he's written like some of our
movies - my favorite movies on the
planet yeah Empire Strikes Back and
Raiders hero so yes but so uh this one
want to talk about for a while night and
because I hate it at all honestly I
think it's very entertaining but all
this was so much going to do let's talk
about they float they uh I okay I'll
give a little history on this uh so I
would always see this movie advertise it
you see the killer clown on there and
stuff like that all my friends doesn't
maybe like fifth grade to something like
that everybody's like oh it's so scary
all that killer clown agreements uh so
yeah but I mean this is my sex did you
see it yeah I think this was like one of
my first introduction to Steven K I see
any nickname everywhere I was like in at
imitating Nate Stephen King master horn
you see his name and that's something
creepy on the book cover and then these
miniseries were coming out so I'm like
okay well let's let's go and it already
takes a lot to scare me even as a kid it
takes a lot to scare me I think my
imagination is too crazy because I
always look at things ten times worse
and I just saw this
I just saw this I was like what does the
scary stuff start that was but that
wasn't scare I thought was kind of
interesting as a kid but I did think it
was at all scary
I find the stuff I when they're kids I
find that part of it more scary the
stuff when they're adults I'm kinda like
that you bet you found it well what part
did you find scary I did this like like
not not dramatic not good just scary I
don't de Husum I think I don't find
clowns scary now there is something
about Tim Curry that even though I
realize he's goofy and we had a lot of
fun with it there I Tim Curry is a clown
that's maybe it's like the idea is kind
of creepy I put this it's just like I'm
not accusing Tim Curry of anything but
it has that feeling of like the creepy
old man in the club that John Wayne Gacy
thing of like me a little kiddy it is
the creepiest part is when he's just
like you know hi kids you want to blah
blah blah that's always the creepiest
part I mean to me I think it's always we
were literally see me get the sharp tear
growing up in Chicago too like in the
late 80s I get it you're hyper where
John Wayne Gacy - yeah cuz like it's
like that that still at that point was
still on everybody's mind so when you
see it it just I don't know I I found
that part of it and what there's also
the added problem of you know your kids
so the whole world seems out to get you
you know it's uh you know you're you're
more defenseless you're you're smaller
room in this giant like ass creepy clown
with the sharp - I don't know I found
that like that now let me prove this way
I found it scary when I was younger now
I don't I find it scarier than the
resident but it's that I don't watch
there's nothing in Stephen King's it
that I watch now and I'm like I'm
terrified they're like not even not even
closer only things that got to creep up
for me like I said what is the you know
come along though kids so that's just
always scary I think it's hard to make
that not you know like the child catcher
and chitty-chitty-bang-bang that's just
fucking terrifying when he comes Isaac
nothing Falls all free
it's like well that guy got like a
Michael Jackson thing yeah yeah not the
come to me thing is so uh since the
creeper yeah that's the thing it's the
creeper l but don't put the reddit Tory
you know when I was a kid now to lobby
it but Wiles get the one that
legitimately got me I actually jumped is
when he's looking at the picture of the
brother the dead brother oh yeah I don't
like him that was gross good that was a
good G if you know like I was a good
jump
uh but everything else I saw this movie
and I didn't go I think it was funny
because I was still a little kid I was
kind of sucked into the story a touch it
yeah in many respects it's not King
always has good ideas like this is a
good idea for a story and a loss or the
basics no I'm not is amazing compared to
part like I like part one and then like
something about when they're adults like
I just lose it the best stuff is when
they're kids um and a train it
translates into the movie as well so I
saw this years later cuz I'm thinking to
myself rent time was a huge Stephen King
dot and it was one of those things where
it was just like what maybe I just
wasn't in the right mindset maybe I just
wasn't and now I'm an adult maybe I'll
be scary now I guess one of those you
guys give it time
and I watched it and not only wasn't
that scary it was hilarious
uh-oh just silly and not frightening it
was and some of these ideas on the way
they do it and stuff like that and
everyone I think there was something so
much fun about doing this one because uh
the well there are two things one the
when we released originally like years
and years ago everybody how dare you
sure this was like our first attack on
Stephen King effing or one of our
earliest ones and all the Stephen King
died our fan ski mountain no there's all
these you just want a you chose arias
and which is the best thing you can have
because then immediately meet there's
gonna be a hit and it still is it's like
one of our more popular videos and is
better but books still is no but on top
of that it was so much fun seeing all
these people come around and say oh
maybe maybe wasn't as scary as I felt
like it sort of sucked out that
scariness which it may respect I feel
bad about that in our respect it's kinda
showing like there were people that
really terrified cloud too terrified to
incur like they couldn't sleep and then
when they see in this
meeting like that Oh like this this is
okay like this isn't actually as creepy
as I thought like I can sleep I can not
be afraid of clowns and stuff like that
so there is something nice about because
the book is scarier the books and the
envision are you trying to represent the
book they ran into trouble I think
sometimes they went with more comedic
hmm you know so there is a lost in
translation problem but or
unintentionally community yeah but the
book still has issues Tim Tim Curry's
best scenes the scenes that creepy out
like you know that that shot of him in
the shower just like this like looking
there's something about all of that
white and just that that pop of color
and those beady eyes like staring at you
just you know that seems like that work
for me but then you'll have other scenes
where he's just being goofy and you know
think it's pretty safe to assume I mean
I'm trying to fake has there ever been a
Stephen King movie that was actually
better than the book I think the books
are always better uh because his his
prose are amazing he really is a good
writer and I think that's kind of
testament because he takes these ideas
that are not actually you know really
shown us Shane makes us Josh it was
really good I never read that what
that's like it wasn't about it yeah that
was more like a novella like you're
talking about the full big books uh
alright in some respects even my shorts
like even homo indirect where the movie
with a movie set Kubrick's the shiny
ha yeah okay all right I wasn't that it
yeah I hear he's open up to I don't I
don't I don't hate the King's original
version the the book version of The
Shining but I'd it's more of a
redemption story I don't find a bit
scary where's the the Kubrick versions
just like evil and that's it this
doesn't worldly what the heck there's no
redemption at the end of that this is
holy shit we survived yeah you know um
um but yeah and as I say a million
million times before I mean it's like we
actually really do like Stephen King
especially as a person I never met him
but I think everybody feels like they've
met him it just seems like one of those
really really cool fucking brilliant
i Percival's ya off like guys what like
yeah that a cool yeah that you weird
friend you always want to have like yeah
like um and he just has a kind of like
this no-nonsense thing about him but not
in a you're an asshole kind of way like
he seems legitimate and I said what we
said he's an amazing writer on the
oniton well amazingly proficient I mean
what what he has a 1230 books I think
somebody yeah it's like you could fill
the Titanic with him if so he's
amazingly proficient and on a technical
level like his writing is just like
flawless their page turners you know he
speaks with the active voice they're not
poorly written
I just the plots just aren't my thing
yeah like that's really what it comes
down to it it translates kind of into
the movies as well where I'm like oh
here's some good ideas but in the end
it's just like a lot of times monsters
and things don't scare me you know
everybody was reading RL Stein in in
fifth grade I was reading King and I it
was a weird feeling because I I liked
them but I also kind of I couldn't do RL
Stein at all like ever you like the
first two pages I'm like shit no
disrespect I just really don't get into
it at all uh by dominating these kids
are gonna get but but but uh but Stephen
King you know I would read and it kept
me really engaged and entertained at
that age and I think you could argue it
still does nice to a good writer it's
just very much that like I don't you sir
catch on to these formulas they keep
coming back but he still writes them in
it's like Tim Burton it's like yeah I
know the formula I know this stuff but
he still doesn't such an interesting way
and it's just kind of stuff I sort of
leaned towards more may not be sake
movies do the same thing yeah I mean
there will be a boy and a girl combo
there will be some entire nature
investigation there will be yeah they
saw some punk they all have that
somewhere Miyazaki style that look about
them but but there is something I think
to me though because like I said well as
a kid it was a good introduction to kind
of like you know scary reading and stuff
like that but as an adult I think there
is a maybe
I know he's a good writer that when I
see the stuff repeated over and over and
over I'm like you lazy tropes I don't
like yeah you know what it feels like it
in in my opinion the funny thing is like
it's a lot of the commentary after a
while I'm like really like we're going
down the same kind I became a Christian
he got a good you you don't like like
crazy on the Morgan Isaac's religion
yeah you know your your hypocritical
religious types um I put I just get sick
of the same commentary because but
that's my problem is some of the tropes
I don't mind we make fun of it was like
okay it's set in Maine he fucking lives
in me that'd be I give hey all our stuff
set in Chicago yeah that's a drug like
you know we make fun of it but it's like
that's a legit reason I don't mind the
psychic kids I'm like okay like haha
this is a Stephen King true but but when
I see the same commentary again I'm
again it's like oh my god can we have a
different theme yeah just a different
theme wait a minute for the Miss drove
me nuts okay if that crazy lady in there
like I'm just like oh Jesus Christ just
kill her now but for example kid again
going back to Burton it's like it's
always gonna be about the outsider we
got it but one outsider could be Batman
another could be Ed Wood those are two
very different people where it's like
okay Stephen King's always gonna have
bullies there is no difference between
like 80 of these bullies they throws in
there you know or the religious nuts you
know or so are these jerky redneck
characters and I think that's sort of
what gets to me is that there's not a
variety in them even though when he
writes them I feel like they almost kind
of come across that way and I think in a
sense I serve what the movies really do
a disservice to is because I think it
kind of moves the curtain that says hey
here's these tropes you're seeing over
and over there very well disguised in
the books but they are these tropes but
well you know what I always get from
King uh like again I never met the guy I
have no idea but just from his writings
as interviews and stuff like that he
really seems like a guy who writes
because he not just because he wants to
but because he needs to you know they
needs to get this stuff out there and I
almost think its philosophy is look
they'll publish whatever I write I'm
just gonna write you know and I am
and look I'm just doing this for my son
yes you did great I'm so hopeful by
doing this for you think that by this
point if he really just wanted to coast
on his own money he could so he's
writing because he likes to yeah well
that's right and when you write that
many things I think part of the problem
is after a while this is gonna be kind
of a rinse repeat recycle kinda yeah
and what and you can and like you say I
think because he has written so many I
mean and nobody writes that much is
they're either doing it cuz they really
don't give a shit or they really love it
and I think his writing is too good and
here mayor views for him not to love it
uh so anyway a lot of the ones that I
like are the ones like I like most in
book form toward like you know your
Shawshank or like Dolores Claiborne a
lot of ones that aren't objects and yeah
I don't want that aren't super intense
yeah that aren't super nature I did
that's the weird thing I think like the
supernatural ones because maybe they
don't scare me that much I feel come off
to me personally as the weaker ones the
ones I'm like matt is interested in and
but I will say this what he does do
really really well is settings cuz
whenever I think of like cool settings
in a horror story I meet it the Overlook
Hotel um you know the mist is a story I
didn't like very much I'm like wow you
made a grocery store and the fog scary
like I I loved the setting I use in like
the way the story played out um you know
there's always uh I think what was the
other one just up that my dream can
happen in our lives
yeah the well not be but I can you know
what in a another one that I thought was
great again the story is goofy is hell
but the setting for the Langille ears
that just you know that's right night
but nobody that was the crew one of the
creepiest things creepiest feelings ever
and was watching the language adjust
that abandoned Airport but what I picked
up nobody there no sound I thought
that's an awesome idea the first thing I
picked up reading a couple of the
Stephen King books was that I always
want to know what was gonna happen I
couldn't die if my hands no such a great
technical right like that NATO's however
if these people when they aren't doing
setups I said Hangul ears I mean just
like how could you not yeah how could
you like
you know the first three pages be like
Nick go read something else it's like
you have to know what's going on you
know I mean these are such good set and
even the clown just like this is clown
going on buddy as candy super nacho is
just like what what is going on and they
just keep going and it was always kind
of like the and then I giant spider yeah
it was Zoey's cut and I know there's
like everyone always says there's like
no no there's a reason there's these
thing and then when you explain it it
sounds worse and I remember like I said
yeah I connect to the other series and a
girl has to sleep with all the boys is
that supposed to make it better no no
the way he write it's always the way he
wrote it and again that is a testament
to a good writer he can make this
insanity sound legit it's hard to
generate to film though well and like
some of the night thing didn't didn't he
admit that he kind of wrote himself into
a corner with it I was wasn't wasn't
wasn't connecting it to the other series
like a retcon that he started to realize
oh maybe this is one of the old ones and
that you know i thing i really give king
a lot of credit for I mean I try thing
how to put this delicately he kind of
acknowledges he's like look if you want
really great writers go read the really
great right I'm flattered but go read
the really great writers he kind of
knows he's not what I try what I yeah
I'm an entertainer I write these
thrillers great it's like and I know I'm
talented but I am NOT your calm ease
great writer no I'm not and I'm not even
say that's a humble thing I know I'm not
compared to like these great books of
literature and these great stories um so
and again that's just something where
it's like I really give him credit for
uh you know because there is kind of
this awareness aid clearly hasn't gone
to his head I need nothing I don't feel
like anything is really going to is that
apart from the drugs um wait again sir
considering his writing is kind of funny
and
sure well you back from overdrive you
just may like yeah I was coked out of my
mind when I directed then you just like
was a Jerry Nick and that one her Tommy
Knox's was it both Tommyknockers he
wrote when he was high out of his mind
and then maximo drive he'd direct and we
as high out as my coked out as my okay
so he said um cuz I thought he said
Tommyknockers he brought when he was
coked out well you know okay a funny
idea again we're taking kind of
different going a little bit of a
different direction here but I think the
videos out you know what's coming up
next a dreamcatcher is the one that we
just did and he am on air view and he
said he really wanted the toilet he
wanted to do for the toilet with psycho
did for the shower it's like that hasn't
been done yet cuz he says he wants to
tap on these things I haven't really be
tapped on yet he says nobody's done the
toilet before I want to see if I can
make that scary and again I have a red
dreamcatcher but I'm sure in the book
I'm sure the book it was way better yeah
but you know it's like you just see the
toilet you say the word toilet you start
giggling um you know a problem with
dream catcher do well we'll get to this
eventually with the AB real thoughts
probably for them but my one problem
I'll jump I have a game and say is that
great idea but it's a smooth eel I get
it as a mouth and teeth on the inside
but I just was like if that thing had
spikes and it came out how I said I
would be super good oh I don't know I
just have a job like they could have
made it waste get like scarier looking
on the outside yeah um but okay but
we're talking about it here so um yeah I
think the big stuff like said the stuff
with the kids is the best even though
there's still a lot of silly moments uh
and when they get to adults it's kind of
the maybe because they're kids we allow
a little bit more of like kind of the
overacting or a bit but I see I thought
the juice Ligeti good yeah I don't know
if it's cuz it was comparison to the
adult actors they seemed a lot better um
but even seems like remember I just
realized I was like yeah they're
children first and then they're adults
in their little goofier this story
doesn't work as well
where's a mic oh yeah drink it ha ha ha
ha we just saw this Oh
even I even dream catcher out I'd argue
it's even sillier but they're kids um
well maybe the the writings that
particularly but but even when
in the mental institution I mean the
scene where it's just I just show people
I rose like oh it is so scary I'm like
let me show you this clip from your
scary film and it would just be like no
I know but number one you're scary moon
no because people were like you know oh
I just couldn't sleep out SOTA and
that's like when they see this scene
it's the scene where like I think Tim
Curry turns into the dog and attacks the
guy and it just everyone forgets about
that scene they watching they just go oh
and then the sort of look at his
colleague from there on the look at
every and of course I'll show the spider
like huh you know I go over the top when
when she discovers her husband's slit
his wrists in the bathtub
[Applause]
it just one on the version we have they
cut the best part because you guys ah
like that then it cuts to whatever just
fill it again it just here Tim Curry
gosh that was so great but yeah the the
adult stuff I thought was definitely the
weakest what you don't like that that
setup of him like you know being dead
and spilled out it with his blood and
the you know wife or mother whatever was
coming in discovery and just what a
terrifying great idea again reading that
that's so scary when you smell like
sorry though by hurry
I don't know and just so the music in
the challenge a you know those little
things I'm like just how much more
terrifying would that be it feels just
like she walks it it's just quiet it's
just so funny why it is not scary as it
is now what does make it is the thing
that's not scary and that's Tim Curry
yeah nobody so much fun so makes that
give you a great cloud real I'm Anna and
that's probably not supposed to think
that but I'm just like I want to met my
party I don't like I think that's what
mate in that in the moments that are
scary with Tim Curry I think is because
of that because it's just you feel like
yeah this could almost be a real clown
and then it always goes that extra step
over the top and kind of wrecks it yeah
but yeah there's so many early scenes
where he just looks like and I've seen
to the new one they're doing and I've
seen some of the promotional shots I'm
like like
removes scary clown makeup not and I'm
like no what made Tim Curry's version
scary is that he just looked like an
actual see what I always kept hearing is
like well that clown just looks silly
I'm like Eve's that clown
it's a box but that's what's supposed to
be I'm coward you don't need to do you
don't need to do anything to Tim Curry
do like you put the clown makeup on this
face that's all you need to do and I
think that's why I kids have a fear of
clowns a lot of kids do um and a lot of
people have a fear of clowns and I think
that's why it's so fucking scary I think
they're like when I see the scary clown
masks and stuff at the Halloween store I
kind of laugh because I'm just like it
would be so much more terrifying if you
just dress up like a regular clown
you know like a lot yeah like
advancements up in the 50s or even those
clowns from the 50s it's like oh my god
I'm just trying to be charming and
that's why Tim Curry works cuz it's like
he's he's playing it like a clown and it
goes over the top but oh good like those
early scenes went a little more subtle
I'm just well I think there's something
- I again I sort of like that now when
people can a quote Tim Curry from it or
not
I love Tim Korean it but I like that now
when they're kind of quoting and talking
about they're doing it and kind of
laughing about it like they're all wah
Wow like now people are having fun with
it and it's not as much see like if they
won't be terrified like you know they
have fun always so scary and creepy -
that's fine I'll talk about the people
that like I guess I just do a lot of
people that were like quote-unquote
traumatized by this film and I just
really like sir going in like look I
mean it's it's okay I mean you're scared
by whatever you're scared by but have
you ever thought looking at from this
angle and I like that just now people
can quote it and have fun I think it
said interesting I think that's probably
the scariest scene in the movie at least
when I saw it the first time of him in
the sewer that is right a scary awesome
wound and like it just one oh and cuz
you don't know what else is down there
it's dark and that exactly saturable
fuckin lot down at the end ya know that
giant and I love stop-motion animation
I am the but this is definitely a case
of like oh that did not hold up no it's
like a fucking Large Marge sequence from
pee-wee's big adventure like it just was
too goofy I got so much of king honest
again I think like all great or is just
what you don't see yeah you know we you
know get my own way of balloons all
colors and each is clearly lying but
it's like what what is down there or
what does he you know you but you can
also get that kids my Lagoon when he
pops up out of the shower just when you
see him out there that's when it's scary
like the it just isn't when it's you
know him doing goofy things it becomes
the giant spider or but yeah I totally
you're unaware yeah I think though I
think those early sees and those are
funny now ironically cuz it's Tim Curry
just chewing scenery and having a great
time but I mean it's not so much scary
we laugh at that now yeah um try think
anything else about it I mean everything
else that we talk about we just talked
about many times with the Stephen King
tropes um I think it's it I think it's
very entertaining honestly I think it is
super entertaining I don't think it's
scary I think the stuff with the kids is
dramatic and everything else is you know
I think the first show of least
something they're they're scenes
early on in the first half that are
legitimately scary but you know I I mean
that's so much as in the dull no but as
a kid terrified that fuck out of me hmm
um but even as a kid like I remember
seeing bits of the second half and just
yeah like yeah it was all the scary
stuff was in that that first heaven like
their parts in there that are really
scary as a whole though like part two is
such a wet yeah such a letdown I don't
know what they're gonna do with the
remake like I'm worried that it's gonna
be the same thing where I'm just very Oh
so when I know there's this big
complicated backstory and stuff I
remember reading a little bit of that
and the button again I'd you so read up
I would so read it but not read it at
the same time like it I wouldn't
prostate can Michals it connects to his
larger universe yeah you know I don't
know if that was intentional or if he
kind of reckoned that like I like wrote
himself into a corner and was kind of
like well then maybe it'll connect to
this so it's out of complete waste of
time I don't know if I mean it's
something I never I never got that
interest
um but you know the actual basic idea
like what is going on was good but then
when they got to the super technicals of
it it's like no no just you know it's
like okay it's like a ghost story it's
like we don't need to know how there's
an afterlife and the tentacles say it's
like no no just who died and why do they
want to kill me you know it's like
that's the basics that we want no I
don't need to know all the technicals
but I don't feel it did that too much it
was only kind of like in the book anyway
it was only candy at the end and the
movie they just said no we're not doing
that at all to their credit um but but
I'm sure you can do that stuff too I
never read the dark towers I feel
they're phenomenal um so maybe he can do
that stuff really well to wander making
the movies now to our yeah so that will
be the big experiment yeah because that
is like just your Stephen King technical
world story it's kind of like is kind
like is lore the Rings kind of thing
yeah and I'm both really intrigued and
kind of terrified because they are good
and I'm just like we've seen how much of
King has been destroyed in the
moviemaking process oftentimes
hilariously so I mean a lot of times
they're still entertained ha ha ha but
I'm like this is one that I don't want
to see it destroyed like you know I
think the King put is hard like it's one
that I think is that they're really
solid and oh god yes I just outfit
fingers cross fingers cross this sounds
like as good people attach so we'll see
happens with that but yeah it's um a
funny movie not specially scary uh and
some dramatic moment but mostly just
kind of silly uh if you like it great if
you're still terrified by it it'd be
terrified of Indian Oprah get your hands
in it how can you know like when people
just like oh it scared me I'm like oh I
get that could not the second half
doesn't scare much but the first half
I'm just like oh if you have a fear of
clowns that fucking movie oh yeah I
guess I guess I sort of thought there
but using my novelty people who have a
fear of clowns are also afraid of killer
clowns from outer space yeah exactly so
I am I'm really scared
I can't
oh no maybe I did have a fear of clowns
cuz when I was like 5 years old then we
weak scared me
so what good or killer quiet before I
guess I'll think we're yeah wasn't I
just didn't want to be in case in cotton
candy all right so uh cool that's about
it we'll see you guys later enjoyed
nostalgia weena ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha that looks so wrong feel so right
this